tonight we're going to do something a
little bit different because for one
week and one week only the show last
week tonight is actually going to talk
at some length about the last week
tonight and the reason we unfortunately
have to do that is the last seven days
have been absolutely insane so much so
that by Friday night it may have broken
Anderson Cooper I tell you why because
Jeffrey Lord CNN contributor and diehard
Trump supporter was in the middle of
defending yet another indefensible
statement from Trump when Cooper finally
snapped he's the president the United
States if he wants to say that Barack
Obama wants to say whatever if George
Bush says I looked in his eyes on if he
dares are you open yes yes that is a
professional journalist save of the
president if he took a dump on his desk
you were defended and more importantly
Jeffrey Lords he's not immediately
awesome no and look on a different night
I could probably devote time to why CNN
would put themselves in the position of
having a professional dump defender
constantly on their network but there is
not going to be time because tonight we
have to track the latest development in
what we've been calling stupid Watergate
a scandal with all the potential
ramifications of Watergate but where
everyone involved is stupid and bad at
everything and given the exhausting pace
of this week's event tonight we are
simply going to try and answer a few
basic questions what the is going
on how big a deal is this where do we go
from here and is this real life so let's
begin with question one what the is
going on and the answer to that is quite
a lot because can can you even remember
how this week began because it was
actually a big story on Monday that you
may have forgotten by now
top secret bombshell
the forks president Trump reveals highly
classified intelligence to the Russians
in the Oval Office sources tell The
Washington Post the president was
boasting to Russia's foreign minister
and ambassador when he divulged the
intelligence during an oval office
meeting last week that's right President
Trump may have inadvertently revealed
codeword information one of the highest
levels of classification to Russian
officials and that is the kind of
information you shouldn't even share
with your closest friends which of
course in Trump's case would be the golf
caddie he called Steve even though his
name is Doug a bucket of KFC chicken and
the ghost of Roger Ailes and back then
back then in the more innocent time of
Monday it felt like they simply could
not be a bigger story than that this is
the most serious charge ever made
against a sitting president let's not
minimize it call me is in the
wastebasket of history everything else
is off the table this is the most
serious charge ever made against a
sitting president of the United States
yeah it turns out Alan Dershowitz was
extremely wrong about that and I would
say it's hard to imagine him being more
wrong about anything but fortunately we
have photographic proof but the point is
the point is that that Russian news was
buried the very next day by this ABC
news confirming that shortly after an
oval office visit in February former FBI
director James Comey wrote a memo saying
that during that meeting President Trump
asked him to shut down his investigation
International Security Advisor Michael
Flynn and that was a huge deal because
let me give you a quick reminder about
why the FBI was investigating Flynn a
man whose overall demeanor says I only
on top of the sheets so I don't
ruin the hospital corners Michael footed
was fired after the most he discussed US
sanctions against Russia with Russian
officials during the transition despite
denying that to the press to the FBI and
to Vice President Mike Pence Flynn was
so floors cleaned Trump was repeatedly
warned about his baggage by both then
acting AG Sally Yates
and President Obama and even as reported
this week general Flynn himself but from
kept standing by him anyway which kind
of makes sense in a way because
literally every decision in the Trump
administration is the worst possible one
paper or plastic
whichever one kills the most birds soup
or salad I'm going to go with the n-word
favorite people
it's got to be Yoko anyway anyway let's
get back to this week because always day
just four days ago
which is the equivalent of 150 years in
2017 times Donald Trump gave the
commencement address at the Coast Guard
Academy and that should have been easy
simply lift the cadet spirits and point
them towards the future but Trump
inevitably use the speech to well I'm
fairly short long and Tony forget the
word certainty and also generally whine
about how many people were being to him
no politician in history and I say this
with great cheering them has been
treated worse or more unfairly wait no
politician has been treated worse
Abraham Lincoln was shot by an actor
William McKinley was shot by an
anarchist JFK was of course murdered by
Ted Cruz's father James Garfield was
shot then to find the bullet and this is
true Alexander Graham Bell devised the
kind of metal detector which didn't work
so doctors try to fish around in his
guts for the bullet with unwashed
fingers which just made his infection
worse so he died in horrible pain but
yeah Alec Baldwin sometimes doesn't mean
impression of you on TV so yeah
basically the same isn't it
later that family day the same day the
Justice Department appointed a special
counsel former FBI head Robert Muller to
conduct an independent investigation
into the Trump campaigns connections to
Russia which is also a massive
development that was closely followed by
Thursday's news concerning James Comey
specifically his friends account of the
lengths to which Comey went at this post
inauguration meeting to try and avoid a
personal encounter with the president
he's wearing if you watch the video of
it he's wearing a blue blazer and he
stands in the part of the room that is
as far from Trump as it was physical
possibly and also against blue drapes
that are the same color as his I chose
that but he chose that spot because it
was you know like almost like a
chameleon camouflage there's a wall
come on Comey it just six foot eight you
don't hide by blending into a curtain
you wear a brown suit you post a few
leaves to your hand and head in your
home to be mistaken for a tree that's
what you do now luckily we've somehow
escaped Thursday alive and on Friday the
president took off for a nine-day
overseas trip but the wheels of Air
Force One had barely left the ground
when this happened
the New York Times now reporting that
according to a White House document
President Trump in the Oval Office told
Russian officials ten days ago that
James Comey the FBI director was a quote
nutjob now yes that sounds rough but in
Trump's defense
I can't kind of see what he's coming
from the guy keeps hiding in my drapes
who does that he's huge
I can see him dressed like a tree you've
got to know that and isn't exact same
document which the White House did not
deny gave the even more concerning
detail that Trump had told his Russian
guests I just fired the head of the FBI
I faced great pressure because of Russia
that's taken off and it's almost
difficult to believe your ears when you
hear something that sounds so
audaciously corrupt it's like if Hillary
Clinton had sent an email with the
subject line sub I did Benghazi
so wait wait because the we still wasn't
quite yet done because almost at the
exact same time that the nut job news
emerged there was one last startling
revelation
The Washington Post began reporting that
the FBI investigation into possible
coordination between Russia and the
Trump campaign has identified a current
White House official as a significant
person of interest and that is also
potentially enormous now some have
suggested that that could be Jared
Kushner but it seems unlikely because
while he is technically significant and
legally a person he in no way qualified
as of interest he is the least
interesting human on earth here's the
person equivalent of an empty room
painted eggshell
he's like a white bread sandwich where
the middle is just a third slice of
white bread or as Mike Pence referred to
that the devil's hoagie so so that is
the shortest possible summation of the
events of this week which brings us to
our second question how big a deal is
this because it feels like a pretty big
deal think about it going into this week
they were already multiple
investigations into Russia's efforts to
swing the election and any possible ties
to the Trump campaign but there are now
also strong allegations that Trump
attempted in some form to influence the
investigations and we now have a special
counsel looking into all of this you
would almost have to be trying really
hard not to see this as a big deal and
nobody tried harder than some
commentators on Fox News this is insane
where is the evidence of a crime people
are now buying some of this lunacy
hysteria every single day we've reached
a point of madness there unhinge this is
a scandal with no video with no audio
with no sex with no money with no dead
bodies it's a boring scandal
having just ridiculous there may be
Americans hidden in plain view working
on behalf of Russia is not boring it's
literally a emmy-nominated TV
show my favorite attempt to call water
on this story came from Tucker Carlson
the villain from a director video
Caddyshack sequel who somehow became a
real boy chucks try to Jedi Mind Tricks
a scandal out of existence the world is
a very complicated place Washington
especially what you think is happening
often really isn't happening Wow
what you think is happening isn't
happening he's talking to his viewers
like a parent whose kids just walked in
on them sixty-nining this isn't what you
think this isn't what you're looking at
your mother and I were just listening to
see if there's an echo when you scream
into a but nothing is happening here
you're not seeing anything here
without fascinatingly as the week went
on even some on Fox were struggling to
hold the line because remember mister
this is a boring scandal this was him
just two days later I've been the first
one to say you know there's a lot of
smoke but I don't see any fire but now
I'm getting a little concerned even I
myself I've got to the point where I'm
like what is going on here with this
situation I'm a little worried about it
that cannot be a good science a Hobbes
host not being able to hold his doubt
survey for 48 hours it's pretty much a
canary in a coal mine but then at this
point Donald Trump is basically
waist-deep in dead Canaries and you can
tell how serious this is becoming by the
fact that when the new started breaking
this week members of trumps own party
was suddenly hard to find we reached out
to 20 Republican senators and
representatives to appear on this
broadcast we also reported and requested
that someone from the White House join
us at any point during our two-hour
broadcast to respond to the latest news
all declined our invitation just trying
to think about how crazy that is 20
invites 20 refusals that's worth
attendance than a wrap party for the
cast of the jinx oh I don't know Bob
where do you think everyone is new
massive creep now now some Republicans
did comment on Trump this week but not
perhaps in the way that the White House
would have ideally wanted for example
John McCain had this to say
I think it's reaching the point where
it's of Watergate size and scale and a
couple of other scandals that you and I
have seen it's a centipede that the shoe
continues to drop yeah it's like a
centipede that keeps dropping the shoes
but it's real and people wear shoes so
the Trump administration is really more
like a human centipede in terms of the
amount of ship passing through it and
how nauseating watching it really is and
while McCain was willing to cite
Watergate other Republicans were willing
to go even further
Michigan's Justin Amash today became the
first Republican to say the president's
actions might merit impeachment and
there
we have it a member of trans own party
has raised the specter of impeachment
just four months into the president's
first term that is almost impressive in
a way and against worse because when
Mother Jones ran an article citing her
Marsh as the first Republican to mention
impeachment a spokeswoman for another
Republican representative Carlos Cabello
of Florida reached out to say he was
actually the first Republican who rented
it although although to be fair we to be
completely fair here the very first
person to think Oh God
he should not be President is probably
some unnamed nurse in Queens in the year
1946 you know I've been doing this a
long time but this baby is the worst one
I've ever seen this is a terrible baby
and respect of his Pietschmann is
something that some in the White House
are reportedly taking seriously and
after days of it Cindy Airy headlines
cNN has learned that White House lawyers
are researching what a possible trump
impeachment might look like that's
actually a pretty good question what
would a Trump impeachment look like
coming ironically I imagine at least
part of it would involve thousands of
Muslims celebrating in New Jersey
Oh screw Karen see of a pretty big deal
which brings us to question number three
where do we go from here and if you are
hoping for impeachment or a resignation
it is worth taking a quick peek at the
presidential line of succession because
Trump Joey would be fantastic but
remember that would give us president
Mike pace and let me write you how our
perspective next president sees himself
I'm a Christian a conservative and a
Republican in that order I'm a Christian
a conservative and a Republican in that
order I'm a Christian a conservative and
a Republican in that order honestly I
would have loved if he just kept going
often after those three I'm a Gemini I'm
a furry and I'm gluten intolerant in
that order that's what I am those six
things don't get it wrong Mike Pence is
a hard-line conservative in Congress he
led efforts to defund Planned Parenthood
he opposed the lilly Ledbetter Act and
the ending of Don't Ask Don't Tell and
championed a constitutional amendment
defining marriage is between a man and a
woman and as governor of Indiana his
most eye-catching accomplishment was the
passage of the Religious Freedom
Restoration Act which could have made it
easier for religious conservatives are a
few service to gay couples and making
matters worse when he was asked multiple
times whether that's what it did he kept
dodging the question ending in this
exchange do you think it should be legal
in the state of Indiana to discriminate
against gays or lesbians George with a
yes or no closure come on losers don't
believe in discrimination yeah well I
don't believe in losses what the is
illusion that don't come from anyway it
sounds like the sound Al Pachino makes
when he sneezes oh yeah
for sure nice job by the way if you're
telling yourself well maybe Trump's
impeachment could take pence down as
well well think about what that would
mean because then we'd have president
Paul Ryan three words that I always knew
I'd have to say but I didn't really
expect to have to say it quite so soon
sort of like remember polar bears or
female entourage reboot the boys are
back and this time they're girls and you
know if you really want to spin this
fantasy out let's say that Ryan is also
somehow sitting on his own impeachable
do you know who is next in
line to the presidency you might not I'm
not sure that you do do you
it's actually mr. Kelsey Grammer I think
you're probably assuming correctly that
that is wrong but what is the real right
answer there I can actually tell you
because we would we would genuinely have
president Orrin Hatch at that point yes
he would be he would be present a man
whose every expression says I take fiber
supplements and frankly they're not
working
look catch if you'd only separate kind
of nightmare but before we get lost any
further down this paranoid wormhole
let's just all take a collective breath
because in reality even though some
people have been getting excited this
week impeachment is a longshot for many
reasons not the least of which is it
would require a majority of the house to
vote to impeach and that is currently
controlled by Republicans and then it
would then need two-thirds of the Senate
to vote to convict the president and it
is also controlled by Republicans right
now so the likelihood is that Trump will
survive this and continue as president
which shouldn't really be a surprise to
anyone why would this be the end of the
line for him Trump has seemed to reach
the end of the line on multiple
occasions only for nothing to happen
remember when he hesitated to dinner to
disavow David Duke wasn't that supposed
to be the end of the line all the time
he bullied a gold star family that had
to be the end of the line right or the
Access Hollywood tape we all thought the
next stop on that bus was you guessed it
the end of the life
but it seems like when it comes to
President Trump he's always approaching
the end of the line but it never seems
to come as if for him and him alone
the end of the line is drawn by MC
Escher and and I know I know
following stupid watergate's every
development can be all-consuming it
feels like nothing else has happened
over the last couple of weeks but that
is a dangerous thing
to believe because it has things have
happened this administration has made
significant moves that have escaped too
many people's attention Jeff Sessions
move to lengthen drug sentences undoing
Obama era criminal justice reforms just
tonight it came out that Trump is going
to propose slashing Medicaid and other
safety net benefits and tomorrow in
court the administration may decide to
end key Obama care subsidies which if
that happens could immediately unravel
the Obamacare insurance markets so that
in 1946 nurse was absolutely right he
was the worst baby and you know he's
still the worst baby now and as if all
of this wasn't bad enough which it
comfortably is we are we are getting
some heartbreaking glimpses into how
this president operates for instance
just this week again we learnt that this
is how his own national security team
feels they have to brief him on
important global issues he like single
page memos and visual aids like maps
charts graphs and photos national
security officials have strategically
included Trump's name in quotes as many
paragraphs as we can because he keeps
reading if he is mentioned
Wow that is absolutely pathetic our
president can only understand the world
to the extent that it involves himself
meaning anything tiny possible that his
security briefing reads the leader of
North Trump King John Trump is making an
intercontinental ballistic Trump this
could seriously jeopardize not just the
region but also the safety of millions
of oh god we're losing you aren't we
Trump Trump Trump welcome back sir
this can all seem like a terrible work
of fiction which actually brings us to
our final question is this real life to
which the answer is unfortunately yes
and if you are feeling miserable about
the situation that we're in right now
the only consolation I may be able to
offer you is I'm not sure that Trump is
entirely happy either because yes you've
seen him enjoy the rallies and the
attention and the fact that he can save
the president but I think the most
telling photo taken of him so far is
this one that was taken on his
inauguration day and a luncheon thrown
in his honor look at his face he looks
like he's at the funeral for every dog
and if you think I'm projecting this
onto him just just listen to an
interview that Trump himself gave around
the hundred day mark of his presidency
and tell me if this is a guy who sounds
like he's happy with this situation I
love my previous lab I actually this is
more work than in my previous life I
thought it would be easier I do miss my
own wife this I like to work so that's
not a problem but this is actually more
work yes of course being president it's
harder than your whole job of course it
is your old job was basically having a
name letting other people pay you to use
that name and firing Dee Snider
it was easy
although I will say this I now actually
have something in common with Donald
Trump because I too prefers my previous
life before he became president truly
she did Watergate because no matter what
we are in for an agonizingly long period
of leaks allegations and recriminations
all over a presidential campaign to put
a man in power who may not entirely want
to be there say what you want about
Nixon at least he wanted the job
look I don't know about you but this
week has drained me at the end of last
year we told you to write down this is
not normal to guard yourself against
getting complacent I don't think there
is much danger of that happening in the
foreseeable future but it is also worth
remembering that sentiment just to
reassure yourself but you're not going
crazy and if you are tempted to believe
any of what people are saying that this
is all politics and every president goes
through a week like the one that we just
had early in our administration let me
show you one of the things that people
were attacking the last person for at
roughly the same point in his first term
as you all know President Obama is a
real man of the people
take a look at him ordering his burger
with a very special condiment like a
spicy mustard on my hair
and I hope you enjoyed that antsy burger
mr. president they were really mad about
that that was on actual television and I
would honestly give anything to once
again live in a time where the scandal
rocking the executive branch was a fox
news host implying that the president
likes metrosexual mustard and lazy
fingers crossed one day we could all get
there again